Trascrizione: Sarah Elhay
Revisore: Michele Gianella
È una croce.
È una croce, e non si deve dire
che è un crocifisso:
è proprio una croce,
nel senso che non c'è il crocefisso.
Anche perché c'è l'imbarazzo
di chi ci deve stare, su questa croce.
Certo: quello più famoso,
quello che ha dato un senso,
anche, a questa croce,
che è detta come bestemmia,
come offesa, come tortura,
è sicuramente Gesù Cristo: il Cristo.
E tutti gli altri poveri cristi?
Veramente, c'è un elenco
interminabile nella storia;
scusatemi, però giusto per capirci
su cosa stiamo parlando
uno di quelli che è salito
su questa croce, due giorni fa,
è un bambino di 12 anni,
si chiamava Salah.
Abitava nel Sinjar,
che è il kurdistan iracheno.
E i turchi, che stanno mediando la pace
tra russi e ucraini,
lì stanno bombardando;
e bombardando, hanno fatto
un morto di 12 anni, Salah.
Un altro che è salito su questa croce
qualche giorno fa, davvero pochi giorni fa
si chiama Mohamed Mahmood Aziz.
Veniva dal Darfur:
19 anni, in un posto di guerra,
dove c'è la violazione
dei diritti umani su ampia scala.
Mohamed fuggiva da quella situazione,
che riteneva assolutamente insopportabile;
ma come tutti i migranti
che arrivano da quell'area,
vengono poi portati, condotti,
segregati nei lager libici
che noi italiani,
e che noi come Unione Europea,
abbiamo finanziato,
insieme alle milizie che li catturano,
questi che hanno la sola colpa
di desiderare di vivere;
questi che chiedono,
bussando alle nostre porte
delle nostre città opulente,
semplicemente pane e dignità.
E c'è un'ipocrisia di fondo,
per cui questi li respingiamo,
li fermiamo nei lager della Libia:
e può succedere, come a Mohamed,
che sia più duro che il Darfur.
Per cui si è impiccato,
si è tolto la vita,
è salito su questa croce.
E c'è un razzismo strisciante,
un'ipocrisia collettiva,
una schizofrenia -
incomprensibile, per certi versi -
per cui i profughi ucraini
trovano assistenza, integrazione;
e quegli altri,
che hanno il colore, forse,
della pelle diverso
non hanno questa possibilità.
Che cosa ci sta succedendo?
Questo è il tema, no?
Non riusciamo a riconoscere più
il desiderio degli altri.
Che risponde ad un bisogno,
a una necessità e un bisogno primario,
quello della vita.
Qualche anno fa, ho trascorso
qualche anno in carcere,
non come detenuto ma
come cappellano - almeno questo...
C'era il nostro direttore
di questo carcere di massima sicurezza,
ad alto indice di pericolosità,
che diceva: "i nostri ospiti"
o " i nostri utenti".
Questo carcerato
aveva fatto più anni di carcere
che non di vita libera;
e come tutti, tutti i detenuti,
aveva anche lui una produzione
onirica molto forte, ecco:
il desiderio, il sogno che veniva
in tutti i modi soffocato -
soprattutto negli affetti,
nelle relazioni appunto,
per una persona
che è ristretta in una cella -
e lui si era fatto un suo percorso
per cui era riuscito, in qualche modo,
a trasformare la cella della detenzione
in una sorta di cella monastica;
e aveva trovato questa capacità
rappresentativa molto forte -
che lo aiutava a vivere, appunto -
in cui i sogni diventavano poi quadri.
E ha affinato una capacità,
anche pittorica, piuttosto forte,
e un giorno mi ha detto:
"Stanotte ti ho sognato".
Io dico: "non avevi
di meglio da sognare?!"
Mi aveva sognato in questa maniera:
nudo - si vede male, forse -
nudo che mi trascinavo dietro una nave -
che ha un significato storico:
la nave di Nelson,
la nave della sconfitta, no?
E però, quella sconfitta viene trascinata;
e nel suo trascinarsi, lascia un solco.
Perché se è vero
che il desiderio e il sogno
danno ampio spazio, poi,
alla sconfitta, alla delusione,
alla paura di non riuscire poi a compiere,
a realizzare tutto questo,
non è mai tempo perso, il desiderio,
non è mai tempo perso il sogno.
Perché in ogni caso traccia una strada,
che altri possono percorrere dopo di te.
Ma è ancora più interessante
che in questo sogno
lui aveva visto Gesù Cristo,
in questo abito bianco, quasi trasparente,
che si scaldava ad un fuoco
alimentato dalla croce stessa:
la croce veniva sconfitta,
e diventava calore per chi ne aveva,
in qualche modo, bisogno.
Allora, da questo punto di vista,
mi sembra che il sogno, il desiderio,
sia assolutamente vicino parente,
come dire vicino di casa,
parente stretto del camminare:
non ci può essere sogno,
e desiderio, senza cammino.
E mi viene in mente
l'immagine di un poeta,
uno scrittore dell'America Latina,
Eduardo Galeano,
il quale a un certo punto dice:
"Perché l'utopia sta li all'orizzonte:
io cammino di cinque passi
per raggiungerla,
e lei di cinque passi si allontana;
allora continuo a camminare,
a percorrere la strada,
faccio altri dieci passi
e l'utopia si allontana di dieci passi.
Allora che cosa serve,
andare verso l'utopia
se non riuscirò mai
a raggiungerla, Utopia?
Forse serve proprio
a questo: a camminare."
E allora, il primo
suggerimento, consiglio,
quasi scaldandoci
vicendevolmente i muscoli
è proprio quello
di non smettere di camminare.
Sogniamo, sognate, desideriamo;
ma camminiamo,
e camminiamo verso l'utopia.
Io, quella che ho visto,
che ho sognato finora,
è quella della pace:
che diventa utile, bella, importante,
una pace che, diceva don Tonino Bello,
più che un vocabolo è un vocabolario.
Perché poi ciascuno -
sono convinto che avvenga così
anche per noi -
se io dicessi:
"Che cosa intendiamo per pace?"
ciascuno di noi ne avrà
un'accezione diversa, un'inclinazione.
I terroristi sono terroristi,
e usano la violenza, si lasciano andare
ad ogni tipo di violenza,
per la pace;
la Russia aggredisce l'Ucraina
perché vuole la pace,
perché cerca la pace:
la pace, no?
E allora, dovremmo essere davvero
molto cauti, molto attenti,
e riuscire in qualche modo
a darci delle coordinate
per seguire una rotta che sia essenziale:
una pace sganciata
dalla giustizia, che pace è?
Una pace non costruita, ad esempio,
concretamente nella nonviolenza,
che pace è?
Quindi diventa essenziale,
importante questa -
non semplice rinuncia della violenza,
non una presa di distanza dalla violenza,
ma qualcosa di molto più importante,
di molto più profondo.
È quello che Gandhi chiamava "Satyagraha",
che era la forza della verità:
ed era un'intuizione profonda e bella,
che dovremmo forse riscoprire
e riproporci continuamente.
Perché se due persone
si contendono un bene,
molto probabilmente arriveranno
ad azzuffarsi, a litigare,
per stabilire alla fine chi dei due
è più forte, è il più abile,
è il più furbo,
adotta le strategie migliori.
Non chi dei due ha ragione.
E allora, nella guerra non vince nessuno.
Non è una partita di calcio:
è semmai un con-vincere,
un vincere insieme,
Allora, se non violenza ha un senso,
ha un senso all'interno della fraternità.
E attenzione: non lo dico
perchè sono prete.
La fraternità non è soltanto un valore
scolpito forte nel Vangelo;
è altrettanto ben definito
nelle costituzioni occidentali,
perché è uno dei tre principi,
forse la cenerentola di quei principi,
della Rivoluzione Francese.
E allora, capite che se
mio fratello non sta bene,
se mio fratello viene minacciato
dalla violenza, dalla guerra,
io non posso rimanere indifferente.
E allora, oggi pensare appunto
al kurdistan iracheno, pensare al Darfur,
pensare alla Siria, allo Yemen,
ad Haiti , alla Colombia, alla Siria -
pensare all'Ucraina.
Anche se a noi purtroppo sembra, quasi,
che ci sia una sola guerra -
perché lì ce ne sono 826,
di giornalisti accreditati
in questo momento,
mentre dall'altra parte
non c'è conoscenza, non c'è informazione:
siamo all'oscuro di tutto.
E allora, se mio fratello non sta bene
io non mi do pace, non mi do pace.
E allora mi muovo, mi com-muovo.
E allora vivo con lui il sogno della pace,
che non è più quello che dicevamo,
una cosa intima, personale,
non è avere la pace del cuore -
che già sarebbe importante,
ma non è soltanto quella;
diventa piuttosto un cammino.
E guardate che è davvero
strano, e paradossale:
ma il luogo in cui la parola pace
è più scritta ed è più citata,
è quella dei cimiteri:
su tutte le lapidi, no?
E noi siamo più abituati a dire
"Che pace in questo luogo",
là dove appunto non veniamo
disturbati da nessuno.
Quindi siamo legati ad un concetto
statico della pace:
non al cammino, che abbiamo
visto all'inizio.
La nonviolenza ci mette in cammino,
la nonviolenza mi fa vivere
la fraternità con l'altro;
e allora, giovedì prossimo
noi ripartiamo con "Stop the War Now",
questa coalizione di 176
organizzazioni, nazionali e locali,
per l'Ucraina.
E ripartiamo, attenzione,
portando aiuti umanitari.
Ma non solo quelli:
stando vicino alla gente,
cercando un po' di condividere insieme
con loro quella condizione.
Perché se porti soltanto
gli aiuti umanitari,
sembra quasi che fai
la stessa cosa che faresti
se ci fosse stato lì
un terremoto, uno tsunami,
un fenomeno naturale,
una sciagura naturale,
una tragedia naturale.
E quindi paragoni la la guerra
ad un fatto assolutamente ineluttabile,
al quale bisogna
assoggettarsi, rassegnarsi.
E non è così, non è così.
E noi vorremmo essere
forza di interposizione,
metterci tra gli eserciti
che si stanno confrontando sul terreno:
e non ne abbiamo la capacità,
non ci siamo abilitati;
è quello che dovremmo creare,
è quello che dovremmo cominciare a fare.
Ma tutti, tutti!
E allora, andiamo almeno
a dire, a quella gente:
"Il mondo non vi ha dimenticati.
E vogliamo condividere con voi
la stessa precarietà, la stessa fatica,
almeno per qualche ora
almeno per qualche giorno"
Stopthewarnow. eu
Vi prego, eh:
spero davvero che qualcun altro
si aggiunga alla carovana,
o perlomeno aderite,
in qualche modo partecipate.
Diventa essenziale:
altrimenti, c'è davvero una disumanità,
in questo senso.
C'è una disumanità,
perché dobbiamo essere capaci
di rimettere al centro l'uomo.
Ecco, vedete: io penso che Gesù Cristo
non sia venuto a fondare, a creare,
a proporre l'ennesima religione:
ce n'erano già tante,
e poi adesso sono ancora di più
rispetto all'epoca sua.
Io penso che il compito,
la missione del Cristo -
insieme ai poveri cristi -
la missione del Cristo era quella
di rivelare l'uomo a sé stesso,
di metterci di fronte
alla nostra stessa nudità.
Ed essere capaci, in qualche modo,
di viverla fino in fondo.
Guardate, a volte mi succede,
scherzo con gli amici:
mangiando una bistecca,
dico che sono vegetariano.
Insomma: l'evidenza -
E dico: no, un attimo:
sono vegetariano non praticante.
E questa categoria del "non praticante"
si applica soltanto
alla fede, alla religione.
Non solo - e quindi non ha senso dire:
sono cristiano non praticante -
Non solo: ma il cristiano non praticante
significa che non frequenta
il culto, la devozione;
e Gesù invece ci ha dato
ben altri parametri,
che è appunto il mettersi
al servizio di un progetto
per la costruzione di un mondo nuovo.
Allora che delusione, scusatemi,
una Chiesa che sia preoccupata
piuttosto delle persone che si amano -
che hanno un sesso diverso,
che abbiano lo stesso sesso;
ma che comunque ci provano
ad amarsi, a volersi bene -
piuttosto che preoccuparsi molto di più
delle mafie, delle guerre
e della violenza.
Allora, vi chiedo davvero:
aiutiamoci tutti quanti,
aiutiamo anche questa chiesa,
questa comunità cristiana,
ad andare avanti,
a creare un mondo migliore,
che sappia mettere al centro
la persona umana.
E vi chiedo di essere
praticanti in umanità.
Grazie.
(Applausi)